John we have so many independent
filmmakers that watch our Channel and I
just have to get this question all the
way first so how is it for you making a
transition from a small any film which
you've joked about being a student film
which it's obviously not but um to going
now transitioning into a hollywood film
how does someone make that leap um I
mean I'm not quite sure how any of this
really happened but you know what's nice
at the end of the day with the movie is
that it all boils down to what's in that
frame so no matter how big everything is
leading up to that point it really is
just simplified down to you know one
shot at a time okay I like that's nice
Kevin now you are not just a lead actor
in the film but you're also an executive
producer for you what does a production
have to have attached to it what does it
have to have in line before you will say
yes to it that's a really good question
you know you're hoping for at least one
or more really compelling elements you
know for me I always kind of start with
charachter obviously because that's like
the first place that I'm gonna be
entering into it and is it a guy that
I'm interested in playing and someone
who haven't played before and some shoes
that I want to walk in for the time that
I'm there and then I would say you know
you got to look at the director and
start to think about whether or not this
this thing that's on the page is is is
going to become you know close to what's
here in his in his mind great John I
have a quote from you recently in any
wire i know our interns ie me and it
says that don't be afraid of paperwork
and don't allow anyone to protect you
yeah from what's happening behind the
scenes yeah do tell how does someone
because a lot of people say hey I'm I
just want the creative part I don't want
to have to worry about all that extra
you know extraneous way yeah i think if
you don't worry about all of it then
things that you're not aware of
eventually end up affecting the creative
so I think it's really smart as a
filmmaker to just be as informed as
possible about everything every step of
the way
right Kevin for you how is being on a
small indie film shoot which I know some
of your family were helping us I know
that's the town you grew up in yeah
similar to touring in a band being
together on the road um yeah I mean I
well when it comes to when it comes to
playing I really equate um live music
with live theater and film making with
being in the studio because you know
it's a controlled you know even in a
case like cop car which was you know a
lot of things having to do with elements
and I really pared-down crew and kids
and you know kids driving cars and guns
and all that kind of stuff you you still
have take two and it is a relatively
controlled kind of situation that's what
the music studios like you know you can
do another pass on a vocal you know you
can you know put overdub something on
its it's kind of like the same editing
process sure in the tour bus experience
tour bus experience is um tour bus
experience is sort of unlike anything
that I've done in the film's up because
I don't tend to share a dressing room
with nine other smelly yeah it's for a
month at a time generally even if my
dressing room is small I'm still not
sharing it with nine guys and sleeping
in a bunk and you know all all that
comes with that